وحيدا بابتسامه تخفي الما دفينا تقدم
الامير هاري المنبوذ او هكذا تقول
البريطانيه مرتديا ستره عاديه عكس افراد
اسرته جلس في الصف الثالث بعيدا عن الصفوف
الاولى المخصصه للعائله الملكيه
المكان كنيسه وست من لندن
والزمان زمن والده الملك
حفل تاريخي للتتويج شهده العالم باسره
الامير الشاب قبيل التنصيب كسر حاجز الصمت
اسرف في الكلام للتغطيه على ما يجيش في
صدره او هكذا يبدو
تشارلز الثالث ملكا للمملكه المتحده
الامير
[موسيقى]
ولي العهد اول المباركين
بينما يقف الاحتياطي متفرجا وسط المهنئين
غريبا عن عائلته الملكيه التي حصلت حضوره
في الكنيسه فقط ولم تسمح له بالمشاركه في
الموكب الملكي العائد الى قصر باكنجهم
والالتقاط الصوره التذكاريه مع افراد
عائلته على شرفه القصر محاسن حداره
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات